uh I'm Matthew Spalding associate vice
president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College here in
Washington DC welcome to the Alan P
Kirby Center for constitutional studies
and
citizenship Hillsdale College was
founded in 1844 by Free Will Baptists
proclaimed themselves grateful to God
for the in estimable blessings resulting
from the prevalence of civil and
religious liberty and intelligent piety
in the
land believing that the diffusion of
sound learning is essential to the
perpetu of these
blessings Gale was the first college to
prohibit in its Charter any
discrimination based on race religion or
sex and was an early force in the
abolition of
slavery it was the second college in the
United States to Grant four-year liberal
arts degrees to
women it has held its core policy of
non-discrimination and today rejects
federally funded grants and Loans from
the federal government and instead
supports its students with privately
funded grants loans and
scholarships the college considers
itself a trustee of modern man's
intellectual and spiritual inheritance
from the Joo Christian faith and the
Greco Roman culture a Heritage finding
its clearest expression in the American
experiment of
self-government hell's kby Center here
in Washington DC extends the college
Mission by teaching students and
Congressional staff public and political
leaders about the first principles of
Liberty and constitutional government to
prepare and shape citizens and Statesmen
necessary to preserve our constitutional
republic our speaker today is a friend
of the college and a
Statesman a graduate of bringham Young
University and BYU's law school he was a
law clerk to judge D Benson of the US
District Court the District of Utah and
judge
Samuel Alo Jr on the US court of appeals
for the third
circuit after several years as an
attorney specializing in appet and
Supreme Court litigation he served as an
assistant us attorney in Salt Lake City
arguing cases before the United States
court of appeals for the 10th
circuit he served as general counsel for
the governor of Utah and later was
redrafted to work again now for justice
Alo on the US Supreme court for a
one-year
clerkship in 2010 he was elected as
Utah's 16th
Senator he's a member of the Judiciary
Committee where he is Chairman of the
antitrust competition policy and
consumer rights
subcommittee he also serms on the armed
services committee the energy and
natural resources committee and the
joint economic committee he is currently
chairman of the Senate steering
committee please join me in welcoming
United States Senator Mike Lee speaking
today on conserving Rel religious
liberty for
all thank you very much it's an honor to
be here I always enjoy coming to
Hillsdale College and thank you Matt for
all you do uh for Hillsdale College and
through the Herby Center
um everything that you do really
advances the cause of Liberty in our
politics and in our schools and
throughout our society and I'm deeply
grateful to you for that it's always
important in any free Society any free
Society like ours to have institutions
like Hillsdale College and like the
Kirby Center that teach and defend the
principles that have made us who we
truly are as a
nation but it is indispensable at this
moment in our nation's history when
cherished ideals are being questioned
and in some cases they're being
threatened as never before today I'd
like to discuss the challenges and
opportunities presented by the
vulnerability of one of those ideals in
particular and that is America's
tradition of religious diversity
tolerance and
freedom in countless ways our tradition
of religious liberty is
best thought of as the dog that didn't
bark America's uh Americans in general
um stand at risk of taking for granted
religious toleration and
pluralism because blessedly we've really
never known anything else we've never
known this not to be the case we have no
comparable scars or memories of the
sectarian violence that has plagued
Mankind in almost every other time and
place throughout the world and
throughout the history of the world and
so that very fact can make it difficult
for us to appreciate
fully the Monumental achievement that
our our religious freedom represents
here in America and also the radical
departure that it was from the cultural
from the various cultures and parts of
the world from Once We Came you see for
most of human history prior to America's
founding a free conscience was not seen
as an essential human good instead it
was seen as something of a threat from
Athens to Rome to London human beings
everywhere believed that religion was
too important a choice to be left to
individual choice the city of God was
submitted for safekeeping to the city of
man so from ancient tribes to Modern
Empires governments derived their
Authority from the church and vice
versa uniform obedience to the
established religion was enforced by the
state and descent from official
Orthodoxy was outlawed minority faiths
were suppressed and heresy was punished
as a
crime America was different not by
accident or chance or whim but by Design
because America was founded by men and
women families and
congregations who turned the oppression
of the ages inside out they we insisted
that religion is simply too important
too essential too Central to human
happiness and to social flourishing to
be managed by and subject to the whims
of mere
politicians these were the pilgrims the
dissenters and the conscientious
objectors who had had the courage to
free flee religious persecution in the
old world and they also had the
conviction to build a community of
religious liberty in the new world they
were extraordinary men and women but
they had an extraordinary an even more
extraordinary Devotion to the belief
that it is not only possible but
necessary to render the things that are
Caesars unto Caesar and to render to God
the things that are gods
the principle they established Was Not
Mere religious toleration but religious
liberty there is you see an important
difference between these two things
under a policy of religious toleration
religious dissenters are accepted at the
discretion of those in power but they're
still understood and treated as
others religious liberty on the other
hand is very different it's a principle
rooted in the natural right of human
beings
to the free exercise of
religion in a letter to the Jewish
congregation of Newport Rhode Island
George Washington praised religious
liberty in America as going far beyond
mere religious
toleration you see in America Washington
wrote All possess alike Liberty of
conscience and immunities of citizenship
it is now no more that Toleration is
spoken of as if it were by the
Indulgence of one class of people
that another enjoyed the exercise of
their inherent natural
rights in practice religious liberty in
America has meant that the government's
job is not to tell people what to
believe or how to discharge their
religious duties but to protect the
space for all people of all faiths and
of no faith at all to seek religious
truth and to order their lives
accordingly as they see
fit no matter who you are or where you
come from regardless of your race or
wealth your political affiliation or
your sexual
orientation to be free in America is to
know you won't be forced to compromise
your conscience at the price of your
citizenship like so much else that has
made America great and except
exceptional religion here breathes in
the natural human space between the
isolated
individual and the
overwhelming overpowering State this
space created by our Cooperative culture
and protected by our constitutional law
is where Americans have always been free
to come together as equals to live and
to love and to pursue our happiness now
government's role as it pertains to
religion and most everything
else is not to direct our interactions
within that space so much as it is to
ensure that all Americans have equal
access to it and equal opportunity
within it when it comes to religion
specifically there have been isolated
episodes in our history when Americans
have fallen short of this standard in
including during the early history of my
own church but this has always been the
standard nonetheless and deviations from
it have been simply that
deviations thus the first amendment's
famous aration that Congress shall make
no law respecting the establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise
thereof the framer's intention here was
not to scrub religion from the Public
Square but to ensure religions equal and
enriching access to the Public
Square this meant welcoming people and
churches of all faiths and people of no
faith to form and to follow their
religious beliefs without interfering
or regulation from the state it meant
permitting government officials to
promote and encourage an environment
where religion can flourish and even to
partner with religious institutions when
appropriate and above all it meant
placing religions on an equal footing
before the law so long as they aren't
threatening the public order the
government must protect the right of
individuals and their associations to
follow their conscience and adhere to
the obligations of their
faith this policy is more than just a
matter of compromise and it's more than
a simple matter of
convenience it is the proper application
of Human Rights and human dignity to the
law in an essay arguing against State
establishment of religion James Madison
wrote over two centuries ago quote it is
the duty of every man to render to the
Creator such homage in and such only as
he believes to be acceptable to him this
duty is precedent both in order of time
and in degree of obligation to the
claims of Civil
Society this is how religion has been
understood in America as precedent both
in order of time and in degree of
obligation to the claims of the state
it's why religious liberty has always
been given exceptionally robust legal
protections against government
interference and in R usion and
infringement and it's why Americans can
be at once so religious and at the same
same time for the same reasons so
religiously
tolerant in short America has gotten
religious liberty right from the very
beginning and we are all every one of us
witnesses to that very fateful fortunate
fact we all know and
indeed many of us are individuals who
have personally benefited in a very real
tangible way from America's commitment
to religious
liberty but those benefits extend far
far beyond the progress reached by
individual pilgrims every great social
reform movement in American history and
this is true from abolition and civil
rights to the struggles for women's
equality and labor rights to the
pro-life movement today all of these
things have grown out of individual
Americans religious convictions and
their constitutionally protected right
to live those convictions out to act in
Conformity with those convictions all
Americans of all faiths and those of
none have benefited equally from our
nation's unique commitment to religious
liberty religious liberty as it has been
lived in America is not to be sure a
mere accident of history and it's not a
mere Quirk of the law it is nothing less
than a culture defining human
achievement yet recent events suggest
resoundingly that it could be losing
ground and we can't accept this we can't
stand back we can't tolerate it we can't
just let it happen the Great American
commitment to religious liberty and
diversity may still be universally
successful
but it is no longer universally
shared this T turned toward intolerance
tragically has been catalyzed by the
campaign for legal recognition of gay
marriage like many Americans I
personally do not believe that same-sex
marriage is a constitutional requirement
or a federal prerogative or even good
policy for that matter but today those
of us who hold these views cannot deny
that our arguments are no longer winning
the public debate sometimes in a
democracy the other side
wins yet today at the very moment that
this particular campaign appears to be
on the brink of success having appealed
to the country with the principles of
Justice tolerance and equality many
within that movement find themselves
tempted to abandon the principles and
the people that have made them
successful
most Advocates of marriage equality are
no more radical than most Advocates of
traditional marriage just as most
followers of Jesus are no more radical
than most followers of Moses or Muhammad
or Buddha but just as radical
fundamentalists exist in every religious
sect so too can they be found at the
extremes of otherwise healthy political
movements we all know the symptoms of
this temptation seeking not tolerance
for their own opinions but intolerance
toward others seeking not to persuade
dissenters but to punish them seeking
not to debate but to
demonize every week there seems to be
another warning on the horizon another
story more reminiscent of an orwellian
dystopia or a Theocratic
Inquisition than the tolerant society
that all of us know and most of us still
fervently passionately believe
in there is the case of Aaron and
Melissa Klein the husband and wife Duo
who ran a small bakery in Oregon and we
recently finded
$135,000 for declining to bake a cake to
celebrate a same-sex wedding ceremony
$135,000 and this came after protests
and boycotts forced the clients to shut
down their Bakery which could no longer
survive then there's Julia Ward a
marriage counselor who was kicked out of
her graduate degree program for
referring same-sex couples to other
counselors who didn't share her
particular religious convictions about
marriage and then just a few weeks ago
there was the ominous exchange between
my former boss Supreme Court Justice
Samuel Alo and US solicitor general
solicitor general Donald farelli during
oral arguments in the gay marriage case
that's now pending before The Supreme
Court answering a question about IRS
regulations from Justice Alo solicitor
general verelli seemed to suggest that
the Obama Administration would be
comfortable with the notion that the IRS
could revoke the tax exempt status of
religious institutions including schools
that maintain the traditional definition
of marriage and stand by that
definition this exchange suddenly raised
the possibility that political leaders
on the left who only recently joined the
ranks of the marriage equality movement
themselves do not in fact stand with the
tolerant National majority of that
movement instead they seem to be tempted
by the intolerant impulse to push
Americans who hold the same view
President Obama and secretary Clinton
did while running for president just a
few years
ago regardless of how the Supreme Court
rules in this particular
case it's becoming increasingly
clear that the next controversies will
not be over whether gay couples should
receive marriage licenses but instead
whether people who don't think so may
keep their business licenses whether
colleges that don't think so will be
able to keep their accreditation whether
military chaplain who don't think so
will be Court
Marshal whether churches who don't think
so will be targeted for reprisal by the
state whether heterodox religious belief
itself will be swept entirely from the
Public
Square but is Father Richard John new
house warned us just a few years ago
quote The Naked Public Square cannot
remain naked politics like nature abhor
a vacuum something is not simply
eliminated it is displaced by something
else close
quote for the
religious for the uh for the secular
fundamentalists who believe
marriage equality must result in
religious
inequality the something else they
insert in place of our open pluralistic
society is submission to their secular
Creed the Creed is simple Americans May
believe whatever they want but they may
publicly Express and act upon only those
beliefs that the government
approves as ever to the fundamentalist
error has no
rights and the role of government is to
codify in our laws the intolerance that
is in their hearts we saw the
fundamentalist Temptation indulged a
decade ago in Massachusetts when
Catholic Charities of Boston was forced
to stop providing adoption services
because they would not and indeed could
not Place children in the homes of
same-sex couples because their religious
beliefs prohibited them from doing so
and we we' seen it more recently in the
case of the Little Sisters of the Poor a
religious order of nuns who provide end
of life care to the needy giving them a
home where they can be treated with love
and dignity and Grace throughout their
Twilight Days by any measure the little
sister's Devotion to the Dignity of
human life is nothing short of
heroic but for the past 2 years the
Obama Administration has treated them
like criminals relentlessly threatening
them
with crippling fines that would surely
bankrupt their
Ministry and for what well for asking
the federal government for permission to
continue operating their Ministry
without being forced to purchase a
health insurance policy that provides
coverage for contraceptives and abortion
abortion inducing drugs against their
religious
beliefs but the government has
repeatedly denied the little sister's
requests insisting that they're somehow
not religious enough to qualify for an
exemption never mind the absurdity of a
group of government bureaucrats in
Washington telling nuns that they're not
religious
enough what's most troubling in this
case and in a growing number of other
cases like it is the presumption that a
free conscience is not a god-given right
but is instead somehow a government
granted
privilege
this is not the posture of a government
operating on behalf of a free
people but rather a government in
service to an official
Orthodoxy you don't need to subscribe to
any particular Faith or hold any
particular beliefs about abortion or
marriage to see the danger of a
government forcing innocent people to
violate their own conscience over a
partisan triviality no
less when they're just trying to make a
living they're just trying to serve
their Community or they're just trying
to educate the Next
Generation the bad news is that some on
the left see this see in In This Very
dynamic in this very sequence of events
not danger but
opportunity the good news is we can
to we should never lose sight of the
fact that the marriage equality movement
is succeeding not by focusing on
marriage but by focusing on
equality we should too focus on equality
political conservatives and religious
traditionalists may not like how the gay
marriage debate is going but it is no
small thing that the gay marriage
movement has succeeded in recent years
only only by adopting our principles of
Tolerance diversity and equal
opportunity and it is those principles
those very principles not the parties
currently enjoying
their political re resonance that hold
The High Ground in this
debate and because those of us who
believe in religious freedom hold those
principles in our hearts and not just in
our political quiver that High Ground
remains still open and available to
us the opportunity exists now and it
will expand if the court rules as most
expected to rule in the next two and a
half weeks or so for Americans of goodwi
to come together to reinforce religious
liberty and to further protect and
enrich not just the free exercise of
religion but also all the free space
that it inhabits and that it influences
soon it seems likely that America's
Public Square will fully welcome married
same-sex couples not as victims or
revolutionaries but simply as equals
just as America has mostly avoided
traditional conflicts between
Protestants and Catholics Christians and
Jews Sunni and Shia atheists and
Believers so too American commitment to
tolerance diversity and dignity is I
think per perfectly capable of making
room for the rights and dignity of those
who
disagree about the meaning of
marriage but good faith compromise of
the sort that is Americans unique polit
iCal genius is Possible only if the
government gives us the space to find
it and those tempted by fundamentalism
will be loathed to afford US this very
space lest they let a manufactured
crisis go to
waste so Americans who believe in
religious freedom who believe in
religious liberty and are committed to
it have two jobs now first we cannot
hide this issue under a bushel and hope
that no one asks us about it we will
have this debate the only question is
whether we start a conversation or we
let the fundamentalists on the other
side of this debate pick a
fight the American people need and
deserve to have this debate so their
representatives must engage it with
cander and compassion in the most
publicly accountable venues possible
this is a crucial point for those of us
who work in capitals and county seats
across the country if the coming
conversation about religious freedom is
left to the judicial and executive
branches of our government acting alone
all Americans whether they know it or
not will lose that debate even before it
begins court rulings and executive
regulations tend to be much more
one-sided far more sweeping and
infinitely more prescri itive win or
take all sorts of propositions a and
thus should have as little as possible
to do with the delicate diversity of 320
million Souls deepest religious beliefs
instead we must Advance the debate in
the legislative branches of government
at every level within the United States
of America at the local state and
federal levels because it is in the
nature of legislative bodies to find
compromise to ground policy in real
world interactions and to respect
minority views and
rights that for instance is what the
religious freedom restoration Act is and
how it came about and why contrary to
propaganda claiming otherwise it has
worked so well now for more than two
decades as President Bill Clinton put it
the day that he signed the religious
freedom restoration act into
law this law the religious fre Freedom
restoration act protects quote the space
of Freedom between government and people
of faith that otherwise government might
usurp close
quote if we want to reinforce religious
liberty in America our first step must
be to protect that crucial space of
freedom from undo government
interference that is the principle
behind a bill I will soon introduce in
the Senate my bill would protect the
tens of thousands of religiously
affiliated schools in America preschools
through colleges and universities from
government
discrimination and it would prevent any
agency from denying federal tax
exemption uh any grants contracts
accreditations licenses or
certifications to an individual or
institution based on a belief that
marriage is between a man and a
woman moving forward the debate will be
less and less about marriage and more
more about freedom of
conscience those of us who value that
basic human right have the better of the
argument but that matters only if we
have the courage to make the argument at
every o opportunity and before every
audience this then is the second and
perhaps the more important task facing
the friends of religious liberty today
we must be more than citizens we must be
Witnesses not just to our own
understanding of religious truth but to
the universal truth that man is not free
unless his conscience is
free as many in this room know to live
as a witness to such a profound and
important fact is to be inspired by and
to inspire in others the quiet
confidence of Truth The Way of the
witness is not through the halls of
influence or the force of intimidation
but through the unassuming power of
example we all have our own Heroes to
show us the
way for me and for many uton our path is
forever illuminated by the example given
to us by the early leaders of my church
The Church of Jesus Christ of latterday
saints you often hear that the first
generation of Mormons were pioneers and
that's certainly true but it misses the
The crucial point you see they moved
from New York to Ohio to Missouri to
Illinois and finally to what eventually
became Utah not by choice but by
force wherever the Mormons lived they
were persecuted as Heretics and driven
from their homes at each new settlement
they would stay as long as they could
until the intermittent abuse grew into
an existential threat and then they'd
move
on there were the not so random acts of
violence suffered at the hands of the
mob that left entire communities trapped
in a state of Perpetual anxiety and
sometimes fatherlessness and then there
were the systematic state sponsored
efforts to destroy the LDS Faith
itself in Missouri the governor used his
police powers to issue an extermination
order against the entire church keep in
mind this is not ancient history this
was in 19 in
1838 the governor's order read quote the
Mormons must be treated as enemies and
must be exterminated or driven from the
state if necessary for the public peace
close
quote but the faithful were undeterred
they continued to push the frontier not
as Pioneers but as pilgrims in search of
their own promised land and as witnesses
to the truth that everyone has an equal
and fundamental right to free conscience
shortly after leaving Missouri Joseph
Smith the church's founder delivered a
sermon that articulated the spirit of
living as a
witness if I esteem mankind to be an
error Smith asked shall I bear them down
no he declared I will lift them up and
in their own way too if I cannot
persuade them my way is better and I
will not seek to compel any man to
believe as I do only by the force of
reasoning for truth will cut its own
way truth will cut its own
way as witnesses to that
truth in our pursuit of protecting
religious liberty we must proceed with
resolve and conviction and also with
cheerfulness and with
Clarity to truly succeed we must be
gracious and civil and
solicitous not only to preserve our own
freedom but the equal Freedom too of
those who disagree with us those who are
though we may sometimes be tempted to
forget our brothers and sisters and
friends just the
same if we can do this as we've done
before the truth will once again cut its
own way and all of us will be free to
follow thank you very much and God bless
the United States of
America thank you Senator the senator
has time for a few questions and Senator
since we're a college our first question
would be from a student uh
Jacob right here go
uh
Senator thank you Senator Leah thank you
so much for coming to speak with us
today um as a
student does how can we protect uh just
not only at Hillsdale but across the
country how can we protect our freedoms
of speech of
Association of religion in general uh
just across the country and on college
campuses first of all I'm I'm pleased
that uh you're referring to those rights
those interests those um values and
virtues as part of a
whole I I I think that's one important
way of protecting them is to understand
that they're related our our rights to
freedom of expression uh to free
exercise of religion uh and our
associational rights uh are all
interconnected and and you can't really
harm one without harming all the others
you can't adequately protect one without
protecting all the others I also think
that as we go about doing this it it it
helps us to understand that this problem
and the need to protect these U these
rights will always have both cultural
and legal ramifications in other words
um we if we focus just on legislative
efforts just on the legal and the
political but we neglect the cultural uh
we might find ourselves ultimately on
the losing side of history and so um
while we'll continue to push for
legislation like what I've described
here today which which I do think is
needed because after all we need to keep
the government out of the business of
discriminating against people based on
their religious beliefs we also
simultaneously need to work on the
cultural component of it and as with all
things the the best way to start with
that is is with yourself and with your
own family with your own community of of
friends and neighbors and what I mean by
this is that in your interactions with
um your fellow students family members
and Friends try to remember that
although you you you don't agree with
the views of everyone around you and you
may often strongly disagree with them
whenever we're respectful of competing
beliefs whether they're religious
beliefs or
otherwise we tend to elevate the public
discourse in a way that that makes our
society as a whole more welcoming of
religious
diversity yes C my name is Cammy but I'm
with the Pakistani spectator and my
question is about religious freedom uh
using uh uh social welfares uh on the
Mormon or Muslim model uh for the people
who are unfortunate or poor or for some
reason are left behind I remember rean
Administration thought it very seriously
adopting Mormon model of helping citizen
uh to get a job or to help them to just
become a productive citizen of of the
society and I my question is being a
member of the church can you push this
agenda to use that Mormon model for for
the country uh because it's very
productive and my second question is you
already addressed that what do you think
about perceived Muslim
victimization uh I used perceived
because most terrorism spring from
Muslim countries and you can't blame
American for perceiving them in such a
fashion but the fact that both your
church and Muslim currently in the
United States share that experience do
you have any opinion about their
perceived victimization thanks okay I'm
happy to answer answer both of them I
I'm not sure I understand the first
question tell me what it is you're
you're asking the first question using
Mormon and Muslim model social welfare
model for the welfare of the citizen who
are poor Left Behind are unfortunate in
our country got it thank you okay on the
first part of the question um I've I've
long believe that uh the very best thing
that we can do as a country best thing
any country can do to Foster an
environment where upward Mobility
economically and otherwise is possible
and where it becomes the norm the best
thing we can do is to strengthen two
institutions that I think are essential
for Upward Mobility economically and
otherwise and that that is uh uh
institutions of Civil Society voluntary
institutions of civil society and uh
free markets when we have free markets
and robust institutions of civil society
and by this I mean the family uh
churches synagogues mosques other
charitable orders fraternal ass
associations and so forth voluntary
associations that are not part of
government the more we can protect those
two things the better off the poor will
be the greater the chance they'll have
of getting out of poverty and so yeah I
I absolutely do believe that um uh uh
your religion and mine as well as many
other religious orders and and and other
components of Civil Society play a very
key role in that in fact it's an
indispensable role if we think
government can solve poverty
um and that if Government tries to do
this at the exclusion of others that it
it will be anything other than
disastrous is folly so I I completely
agree with you on that that needs to
happen as your second question yeah I I
do think um
uh people of
uh people who belong to my
church and people who have any kind of
Faith the the type of which has caused
them or their ancestors to be the
victims of uh religious discrimination
share a special
kinship and
um for that reason
um I'm always on the look at for other
religious minorities and making sure
that they're not singled out for
discrimination um either by fellow
citizens or even worse by the government
itself for any kind of discrimination
and I I think we're very much United in
that hi Senator John
W um is it
on thank you um on the question of
culture your answer to the first uh
question um I think anybody in this room
who agrees with you um especially as a
young person is probably aware of the
fact that um one of the obstacles to the
cultural question for conservatives is
that opposition to same-sex marriage has
become uh viewed by some percentage of
Americans especially the younger they
skew as a form of bigotry or racism so
how do you in the Public Square that's
not really as relevant to the
legislative component but in the
cultural uh argument how do you
personally answer that particular
question yeah I I I think that's
actually very consistent with the point
I was trying to make there um is
that the marriage equality movement has
been very successful largely because of
the appeal of the part of the argument
that focuses not on marriage but on
equality and so too those of us who feel
the need to protect uh Religious Freedom
by
protecting all people of religious
belief and all people of no religious
belief as equal would do well to do the
same and to uh to make clear to others
that particularly When government acts
government needs to be very careful to
act with
neutrality and uh to to treat people
equally regardless of their uh race and
in particular regardless of their
religious
belief um and
um I I I think we would do well those of
us who are concerned about religious
freedom would again do well to remember
that the marriage equality movement has
been successful largely because it's
focused on
equality did you have a followup on
that do you think that that question
though you you kind of talked about
allowing space for people of All Views
to have those views but do you think
that point of view that I articulated
that this is a form of bigotry needs to
be engaged
and how if so how Okay um I I don't
doubt that there are people out there
who hold bigoted views in this area I do
however think that it is uh a mistake to
say that anyone who doesn't share the
end of the uh religious or of the
marriage equality view does so for
bigoted reasons I I think that's
incorrect um but yeah I think it's
important to have the discussion and and
to focus on the fact that there are
reasons that have nothing to do with
bigotry why some people hold that
[Applause]
view